[Music]  hey girl  I noticed below and the conversation let  me ask you a question do you like magic  does that just happen you don't have to  say a thing just sit back and watch  that's right please matches your magic  girl these aren't the only tricks I know  just most of them maybe I could take you  home  show all your friends how I can make a  wine corks stand up maybe even make you  my steady girl make you balloon animals  shake a pencil really fast so it looks  like it's bending I can steer your nose  and make it look like my phone is coming  clean off my hand and hey girl I think  there's a brand new quarter in your year  hmm no I can't tell you how I do it but  I can tuck my willy between my legs and  pretend I'm a lady  and I'd say that's right  that just happened how'd I get so good  girl I guess I just get lonely sometimes  [Music]